your bootleg cat podcast we got my guy
on BPZ his new project misguided is out
everywhere yes sir and uh this is the
fourth freestyle we've done the number
four number four let's get to it so far
you got the three p Bud three feet three
feet let's make it four
camera
[Music]
yeah hey standing up in my room I watch
my thoughts as they bones off the Wild
and lost it all on top of it gotta call
they say I love my dog [ __ ] said I
should be paying her what better watch
them out no braids she get out the car
I'll break the signal stop them all
cross a [ __ ] like hot assault he was
scared so he copped out imma do the time
never drop it down even if I met a wise
out he was running when it popped out he
didn't see the [ __ ] that I saw they
wanna hear about what I bought they
don't wanna hear that wrong [ __ ] I'm
sick and I like slang and I like sling
of that when we in Ward ain't no club
and I can't take the vibe trying to put
so many [ __ ] up in the air shake the
sky cause imma take care everybody like
they try to take mad they try to take
mad money and murder baby that's all I
know when they smoke I want dead [ __ ]
this is all I roll hey can't be with a
hoe cause he gonna tell a lot of note
and when you deep in that sale time
don't stop but they're going slow if I'm
broke they still be hating on me uh if I
get loud babe would you be waiting on me
love wonder why they problems always
laid on me my heart gone you can move in
I got a vacancy
on the way to the Beatles if you ain't
an artist then you supposedly
[Music]
no case
no case
OMB Peezy no cave freestyle that we got
caught up right here there's no case
freestyle charges drops
misguided out now
I know you just watched a brand new
freestyle presented to you by our good
Folks at LRG don't forget if you go to
LRG right now the website will be right
there broom eldash
r.g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get 30 off your order that's L Dash R
Dash g.com you'll see it right down
there save 30 off your order by putting
in that promo code bootleg and shout out
to LRG we got another freestyle coming
next week